or micro remote in wwe2k16 really just
want to listen to the fans so for us
that really meant giving them all the
tools to tell their own story lines this
year you'll have the choice to play out
my career the way you want to go start
off as one of the top rookies in NXT
you'll work your way up through the
Performance Center through NXT from
there you'll have all the choice in the
world
you'll be able to stay in NXT and be a
long time champion or you can go to the
main roster and go for Intercontinental
title or WWE world heavyweight titles
and all that is with the goal of
reaching the Hall of Fame nicely done he
picks up the win now that's having a
game plan and executing it to perfection
this year really is all about freedom of
choice and one of the big choices you're
gonna have is how your superstar looks
and feels that reacts in certain
situations both inside and outside the
ring you're gonna get these post show
interviews where Renee young is going to
give you serving Spitfire questions and
you can answer them in a variety of
different personality types you could be
very aggressive and sort of talk down to
other superstars or you could be very
respectful each specific superstar on
the roster is watching what you're doing
and reacting to it from there you're
gonna Forge some pretty awesome
alliances and get into some very very
heated rivalries over the course of your
15-year career
Oh
no no this just assault using the
championship sending a message to the
Challenger the authority plays a big
role on WWE television and we wanted to
have that in my career for 2k16 as well
on WB television you see Triple H you
know really pulling the strings of
certain superstars career you know for
better or for worse you're gonna have
that decision as well in my career you
can defy the authority or you can work
with them depending on your decision
you'll have a vastly different career
you can't lay a finger on our CEO
without some repercussions he's learning
that tonight with run-ins in my career
you have a lot of different choices you
want to make you'll be able to run in in
a variety of different ways you can do
rematch mid match you could run in from
the entrance ramp or through a barricade
you can attack some from behind or
support a different superstar by
distracting the referee or distracting
his opponent and all this will get you
different rivalries and different tag
team partners tech teams are new this
year for my career at WWE 2k16 you'll be
able to get into specific rivalries with
all of the top WWE tag teams the big
goal for my career this year is to reach
the WWE Hall of Fame and there's gonna
be many ways to do that you're gonna
learn to like some really big milestones
such as trying to become a Grand Slam
winner so winning all the championships
within the span of your career you could
also try to go for the goals where
you're almost like a glorified midcard
superstar going through matches for
three years putting on entertaining
matches but losing them as well so it's
gonna be up to you how you want to reach
the Hall of Fame
Madhavi just changed congratulations my
career for this year's gonna offer more
variety than ever no matter how you play
you can have your own unique storyline
in WWE 2k16